- People have been sending me tweets
from @BadLegalTakes for a while,
and I've really been enjoying them.
And one of the ones that got my attention
was originally a tweet
from PragerU who asks,
"Is the death penalty ever moral?"
And I'm sure PragerU has
an opinion on the subject,
but the thing that got the
most attention was the reply
from Redheaded Mermaid who tweeted,
"No one gets the death penalty
that didn't agree to it
with their attorney present.
You watch too many movies."
- I don't know where she
could have gotten this idea.
I suppose that we all
agreed to the legal system
through the social
contract, but it's kind of
a philosophical fiction.
Yeah, I mean you're
convicted involuntarily,
you're then sentenced involuntarily.
No one really agrees to the death penalty.
I mean, there have been
a handful of situations
where people have refused a pardon
or requested the death
penalty for political reasons,
but those are the
exceptions, not the rule.
No one else really agrees
to the death penalty.
Now you know!